こんにちははじめ社長です
あの動画のタイトル見てもわかると思うんですけども
ちょっと不思議なことが起きましてあの今日はそれについてのお話をしようと思います
であの私はじめシャツお湯チューバーやらせていただいておりまして
こんな私にもありがたいことに版というものがいてくれています
ファンの皆さん
いつもありがとうな愛してるぜ
という話をしたいのではなくてプレゼントとか手紙をよくいただきます本当にあの
くださる方いつもありがとうございますあの時間がある時にちょっといろいろ見たりし
てはいるんですけどもその中である人から
前に砂インチ手紙が送られてきているんです
すごくないですかなら手紙よくもらったりするんですけど毎日を送るか立っていなくて
めっちゃこちらにもあるんですけどもちゃんと埋めに僕宛で送ってくださっております
ピュッ
すごいですねいやもうすごいポイントその5は毎日ちゃんとを送るところだと思います
継続は力なりと言いますいつもお手紙ありがとうございますちなみにこの毎日の手紙一
から来ているかといいますと
3月の15日今年に入ってからですね今年の3月からずーっと手紙を毎日を送って
いただいておりました本当にすごいお手紙をいただいておりますでは月
記念すべき1枚目見ていきましょうあのー
内容は
シンプルですいたってシンプル
てが詩人です詩人と言うべきか分からないんですけども
とりあえず見せましょうまず最初に届いた手紙こちらはい今日誕生日なんです自分への
プレゼントとしてアバのパーカーを変えますこれじゃないんか言うじゃないアバン
ティーズなん
どういうことだまあ誕生日だったんですよねおめでとうございますただあダンディーズ
のパーカー買うの
何故俺に言う謎は深まるばかりです次行きましょう次の日のお手紙はコチラですね
私の少女時代のバイブルリボンでタバコ描写が nc 2信じられない
厳しくない何でも規定ってそれでは聴いてください
r 指定で帰省中俺関係なくないまぁそうですよねいる世の中いろいろ規制が多くなっ
てきますよね本当にとかあってもその
r 指定の曲めちゃくちゃ効くわけでもないしリボンもわからないしタバコも吸わない
であの
関係などで俺夏は深まるばかりです次に行きましょう
こちら
おおぉ弾みへの入会してみましたありがとうございます
さあありがとうまんぷるー
やばくね3枚目の手紙にしてようやく僕に関係することが出てきたというと何か違う
凄いきれいとか時国なんですよねちょっと相田みつをさんは礼装される感じですねって
言うかめっちゃ続くんですよどんどん行きましょう
35歳なんて恥ずかしくて外歩けない35歳なんですかね
わかんない年齢はわからないこれがまずこの方のことを言ってるかわかんないんです
けど35歳そんなことないですよ
前
んでそうだべきなっては35歳でも
35歳なのかな農家の全然反応かどうか年齢全然気にしてないんでこれからもよろしく
お願いします35さんなのかなあと関係ないことたくさんを打ってくださるので
35歳っていうワードが出たからといってこの方が35歳か限らないんですよ
謎は深まるばかりです続いてこちらです人はなぜ旅行前やになって慌てて準備を始める
のか
私だけ終わらんパスポートど
紅陵高に行かれるんですねどこに行ったんでしょうか
あの僕あんまり旅行とか興味ないんで全然行きたいのがそれよくはないんですけど
お仕事で海外行く時とかパスポートをなくしますよね良い旅になりますように
俺関係なくには5万ようなステの関係あるのファンクラブ入りましただけですよ
ええっどういうことだ盗んでいきましょう続いてはこちらですただいま堅実
何があったんでしょう佐賀空港の駐車場が無料なのが本当に助かる佐賀県なんですかね
いや分かりませんよた空港の駐車場は無料らしいです皆さんご活用ください
これなんてもうついにで課金と日か気のせい金の対面
なるほど製品さんと正気をかけてるんですね
俺関係に入って言うとかもう毎日毎日送ってもらってるんです国へ
すごいよあると思ってできることじゃないですよこれ明日護衛も書いて下さったりして
ますありがとうございます
きっ
持って
きゅぴ2クックッキッキッケッケッ
おーすげー8しばらく見てないタイプ
警察には届いてないよう中にはポイントカードをたつかず2れ間使われるときはそう
楽々
くべかしてれかにもか今どこにあるのかな教えてくれよああ神様
いいえ
パットも書けるんですね
ん
おっ
ああああああ
始めましょう ponta カード1万ポイントもすごいですが t カードに
240万ポイントも入ってることがいらっしゃいました
えええ
不正に入手したんじゃないか疑ってるんですねいき
きっ
あっはぁ分かりますや日本もそうですよ
黒いマスクつけてる人見たら僕まだちょっと不自然に思いますの
バッハ
わかるわかりますその気持ち botanica で使うとなんかね僕も抜き酷くなっ
たんじゃね一時期
いやいやもう3つをよ
楽ちんなものは水をですよもう
あと釣りいただきましたーーー
もっふ
ただのポストカードやんけはすぎないのかああそうか大人気されたんですねはいって
いうのをですねもうずーっと送ってくださるわけですよ
あっはぁ
うーん確かにねほんとにもう僕に関係ないこととか何でも書いてくるんですよね
ん
はいという感じでほぼ毎日手紙送ってくださる方がいますたいというわけですねあの
その日最初はちょっと何なんだろうって言うことなんか不思議だったんであのこんだけ
毎日で帰っていただけるとなんかすごい逆に
なんかすごい
いいですね面白いなかなかファン桁とかじゃなくて本当に何かもう本当の間三頭山の c
ではないですけどあったことが思ったことただたを送ってくださる方だったんで何
だろうとすごいなぁと思ってあの動画にさせていただきましたすいませんあのやる人が
際の巣を楽しませていただいてるんであのこれからもぜひ送ってくださるとありがたい
です
すごいよね
何か着い神の在り方を考えさせられるだと思いますか
こういうのか何気ないのボックってゆっくり一揃いないですからねほんとにちょっと
不思議だなぁと思ってどうもにさせていただいたんですけども
ちょっと僕はこういう手紙をもらってほっこりしたなって思いました
よかった怖い人じゃなくてすごい楽しませていただいているんで
これからもぜひお手紙の方お待ちしております何がすごいかっていうとねこういうこと
を前にし続けることがすごいなと思いました
どんな些細なことでも毎日続ける事って本当にすごいと思うのでこれからもお待ちして
おりますじゃあな
すげーいい動画になっちゃったん
me
あっはぁ